How do you
make coffee as good as the princess?Does anyone
know what a barista is?When it comes to tuna, there is a barista training course.I've
never heard of them.Barista
is an Italian word.They are
thought to be coffee experts, but they actually make coffee.  I heard that you are referring to a
specialist in non-alcoholic beverages in general, including non-alcoholic beverages.Some
people call themselves barmans who pride themselves on being experts not only in beverages but also in everything from store equipment to customer service.I am
aiming to become that barman.
Well, if you get promoted at Mac, it'll probably be a big deal.
[Music]
Well, if you want to catch up with my skills,
why don't you take this course? If you have experience as a time zone manager, the
tuition fee will be waived.  It should be hey